bonjour david rigoulet roze merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france les états unis qui vont donc
des armes à l'arabie saoudite malgré
l'engagement de joe biden de vouloir
mettre fin au conflit et minutes de
façon diplomatique
comment expliquer ce paradoxe
oui effectivement le 4 février dernier
joe biden avait annoncé qu'il mettait
fin au soutien militaire directe à la
coalition rabot s'il est mené par ryad
notamment en cessant les livraisons
d'armes en plus des limitations
inhérentes d'accès anciennement donc
c'était un signe politique effectivement
il ya un retour sur
la décision qui avait été annoncé à leur
retour partiel c'est un univers et sont
limités mais si ça montre que la
situation au yémen effectivement est
problématique et c'est sur demande
pressante de ryad évidemment que ses
livraisons sont fait c'est aussi un
message probablement adressé à l'iran
puisque l'iran soutien à la milice
outils et que la milice outil a décidé
de faire une pression très soutenue sur
la ville de marib avec l'objectif de la
faire tomber on parlait de message à
l'iran mais quel message ça envoie
également à la communauté internationale
de façon plus large parce que il ya un
double discours également par exemple de
la france a accusé par des ong de vente
dr marianne qui seraient utilisées
contre des civils au yémen
oui il ya les ong qui effectivement
stigmatise la politique de soutien
militaire à la coalition la situation
est extrêmement compliqué d'abord il n'y
a pas de renouvellement de contrat c'est
souvent des contrats qui ont été passés
antérieurement et puis ensuite sur le
fond il ya également une réalité sur le
terrain c'est c'est cette pression
militaire effectué par par la milice
outil qui encercle aujourd'hui la ville
de marib il ya un enjeu humanitaire sous
jacent puisque aujourd'hui à près de
deux millions de personnes alors que la
population était de 400 milles au début
de la guerre notamment des déplacés donc
c'est cette situation extrêmement
compliquée tout le monde finalement est
dans une impasse et
personne n'a trouvé le graal pour sortir
de cette impasse et les relations
washington ryad s'étaient refroidies
depuis l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche en souvient le président
américain avait promis de faire je cite
payer les dirigeants saoudiens pour leur
responsabilité dans dans l'assassinât du
journaliste saoudien jamal racho dit
qu'est ce que ça traduit cette vente
d'armes que joe biden change son fusil d
épaule ou que finalement c'est pas lui
qui décide véritablement avec la
realpolitik elle prend le dessus
non-échange pas de fils des pôles parce
que la position américaine a été assez
claire n'a été énoncée ottawa par le
secrétaire d'état anthony blinken c'est
c'est la prise là
le fait qu'effectivement il ya une
impasse stratégique humanitaire au yémen
mais que manifestement aussi il ya de la
part de de la milice outils une mauvaise
volonté avérée d'ailleurs qualités
souligné par l'envoyé spécial américain
timothy lane parking qui est un peu
décontenancé effectivement par rapport à
7 à cette posture de la milice outil qui
n'a pas forcément d'ailleurs l'agenda
iranien gardien une spécificité game
élite propre à l'échiquier politique et
ménitré donc c'est là où c'est
particulièrement compliqué à gérer parce
que l'aide de le soutien de l'iran
n'implique pas forcément
le des ordres donnés par téhéran donc
c'est en fait c'est il ya effectivement
il ya un faisceau de d'éléments qui ce
qui se télescopent et qui complexifie
davantage la situation comment expliquer
que cette information les 280 missiles
air air vendus par washington à à ryadh
ne soit que peu relayée dans les médias
elle valait train de toute façon
justement ne serait ce que pour pour
mettre en porte à faux
la décision de clermont tac au 4 février
dernier de la part de l'administration
13 de bayonne qui a succédé à celle de
trump mais il n'y a pas de remise en
cause sur le fond parce que de toute
façon il ya l'objectif politique qui a
été affichée par washington
qui a fait comprendre à ryadh qu'il
fallait trouver une solution alors le
problème c'est un quel prix évidemment
parce que riz yade doit sortir la tête
haute de cette de cette aventure
malheureuse au yémen pour les deux côtés
d'ailleurs
particulièrement pour les yéménites et
donc c'est un élément parmi d'autres
mais il n'y a pas de changement j'avais
dire stratégie de posture de la part de
washington en la matière simplement il
ya un gars des éléments déjà les dires
nécessité fait loi sur le terrain parce
que la collection veut empêcher que
maric tourbe et donc à la besoin
effectivement d'un
armement pour pour effectuer les raids
et bloquer l'avancée des outils dernière
question on avait vraiment les rois
c'est ce que vous voyez une issue à ce
conflit dure depuis 2000 14 lots à nu a
estiment qu'il s'agit de la pire crise
humanitaire au monde oui les nôtres même
benisse temps qu'ils se décident hélas
également mais effectivement c'est une
tragédie humanitaire il n'y a pas de
solution politique d'ailleurs tous les
envoyés spéciaux de l'onu ont lancé
ligne à plusieurs reprises mais ils ont
aussi constaté les obstacles des deux
parties d'ailleurs pour parvenir à une
solution négociée on peut ajouter à
descendre 2018 avec l'accord de
stockholm qui esquissaient une porte de
sortie politique justement mais
malheureusement il n'a pas été
totalement finalisé et on voit bien avec
la bataille de marib que que l'enjeu est
considérable et d'ailleurs le premier
ministre yéménite considère que l'issue
de la bataille de marib va déterminer
assez largement l'avenir prochain du
yémen merci pour cette analyse et ce
décryptage david rigoulet roze je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef de la revue orient stratégique